welcome all of you it is my great
pleasure to
moderate today this panel discussion
that we have organized on the question
of syria and the possibility of
a military strike against syria
my name is frank griffel i am the chair
of the council of middle east studies
here at yale it is my great pleasure to
as i said moderate and also introduce
the panel before we start i should
stress that all of us on this panel just
speak in our own name despite the fact
that we do actually have employers that
with that we also to something we
represent these employers we speak only
in our own name and we do not speak in
the name of any organization or
institution where we actually work
i would ask you in this case to also put
your
mobile phones on
on vibration or better even put them off
in order not to disturb the panel what i
will do now i will introduce the panel
briefly and give each one of the
panelists a certain amount of time for
opening statements
overall i hope that these opening
statements will not take more than three
quarters of an hour so that we then
actually can engage in a q and a with
the audience
first on my on my right here is uh
professor allen lost oaker she is
associate professor of political science
here at yale well-known on the campus
she's been at yale for more than 10
years
and she works on various countries syria
jordan
libya and egypt and has received
numerous academic awards
most recently
she actually was for one year at the nyu
law school
next to her is charles hill
diplomat in residence and distinguished
fellow at the international security
studies program here at yale
he was in the past a fellow at the
hoover institutions and has also a
distinguished career in u.s foreign
service as well as the united nations
next to him is dr hassan barari
associate professor of international
relations at the university of jordan in
amman
he taught middle east studies at the
university of nebraska and was a senior
fellow at the u.s institute for peace
he's a columnist in jordan for jordanian
newspapers and has published widely in
the field of middle east studies
emma skye is a visitor at yale oh sorry
that's not true is a is a fellow at yale
and uh
uh it's a senior fellow to be precise
at the jackson institute for job for
global affairs here here at yale
she has worked she's a british citizen
and has done aids work in the middle
east and worked as an advisor with the
u.s provisional authority in iraq she's
been a visiting professor at king's
college london a fellow at oxford fellow
and fellow at harvard's kennedy school
of government
finally last but not least in this case
is muhammad al-fayoumi who's currently a
yale world fellow and if he is not the
yale fellow he is actually in the
foreign service of egypt where he was
most recently posted to the egyptian
embassy in syria where one of his
responsibilities was to hold contact
with the syrian opposition movement
so you see many of us on this panel in
this case have lived in the middle east
some of us come from the middle east and
others are renowned expert on american
fallen policy i first give the word in
this case to professor allen lust
for her opening comments
thank you
thank you frank for convening this
and colleagues for joining and all of
you for attending what i think is an
important uh important topic an
important discussion and frankly in my
case i think a very humbling one because
i would like to sort of feel like i had
the words of wisdom and all the
solutions and i feel very very far from
that
what i wanted to sort of suggest today
is frankly that not much changed on
august 21st
and that in some ways i find that
somewhat frightening
first of all what not much changed and
that may seem surprising right all of a
sudden we had a national sort of an
international crisis that hadn't seemed
like a crisis before and all of a sudden
this is a sort of a major issue on the
sort of u.s certainly domestic agenda
and on the international agenda
interestingly though in some ways
despite the ways in which that seems
like a new and obviously it's an
important
event
it wasn't the first time chemical
weapons have been used against domestic
populations right we've seen that in
iraq we've seen that elsewhere it wasn't
the first time that we actually knew
that the syrian regime was willing to
use force and to kill its own people
we've known that for a couple of years
now
in many ways if you want to be able to
say that the syrian regime goes back
farther into the father's period we've
known that for decades right um it
wasn't actually sort of also a change in
the regional and in the international
issues in the constellation of issues on
the table and i think that's important
because
one of the things that got lost in the
early sort of reaction to what were i
think really horrific pictures and
rightly so they're horrific pictures
was the fact that the same sort of
issues that were on the table the
regional ones and the international ones
that had stopped us from acting prior to
this
hadn't actually changed we still have to
worry about iran and russia and what
they would do we still have to worry
about sort of the kind of the spillover
effects in terms of lebanon and jordan
and and elsewhere and none of that was
really really changing and finally would
argue that there was nothing really
changing with regards to the balance of
forces between the rebels and that and
the government so in some ways right we
have this huge change and on the other
hand in some ways there's there's
actually not a lot that's that's
different and and i think that was
important because you really essentially
pointed the biggest issue and the
biggest sort of
point of the crisis was the fact that
there had been sort of the kind of the
line drawn in the sand right this was
the red line that wasn't supposed to be
crossed and it was crossed so there was
an issue of credibility there was an
issue in terms of sort of what we had
said we would do and what we could react
to then which was a very much a
diplomatic issue in a domestic issue but
but all of the kinds of parameters
around it hadn't necessarily changed
um if we were to step back and i can
discuss this more in the q a if we want
but i i would argue that the concern
that then would be raised right so the
reaction to that right there was a
couple of possible ones one would have
been a very immediate strike kind of a
you know israelis hostile strikeout on
sort of targets immediately that could
have been you know very limited and kind
of gone with sending the signal
fulfilling the promise and not
destabilizing the regime or doing too
much
that obviously time has passed so then
the next sort of question was can we
move to a period where we talk then
about limited strikes and it was an
interesting period because it's one
which now i'm talking about slightly in
the past tense because it seems like you
know sort of events move on quickly but
it was a period when the issue was to
have a strike that essentially fulfilled
the promise but didn't really do too
much right so the idea that was that was
sort of being bandied about was having
it be limited enough so it didn't
actually kind of provoke the rest of the
of the regional actors
i thought frankly found that very
disturbing and again we could you know
it may be sort of a time we don't
necessarily need to talk about it as
much but i found it disturbing because
in my mind what it did was actually help
to kind of further empower
bashar al-assad because in many ways
there was a rallying effect that was
going on inside syria right all of a
sudden the call that the united states
you know was letting syria be next on
the list that went from syria back to
libya and back to iraq was being sort of
bandied about and in really mobilizing
and i have personal experience with this
sort of the hatred against america and
against this kind of intervention and
therefore the support for bashar from
people who normally wouldn't actually be
so very supportive of bashar right so it
was actually kind of an interesting way
of trying
effectively sort of shoring up the
regime
and again sort of more importantly there
was questions about sort of as you were
if you were moving people and others
into into the to the strike zone then
what were what was the the damage that
was going to be done as a result
so i couldn't say i was very excited
about limited strikes i i think in some
ways i mean if if it's true that
that the sort of the proposals that are
now being banded about and the idea of
having international control over
chemical weapons is actually serious on
the table and then what it leads us to
is still thinking about what has changed
and therefore what next i mean that's
what i want to spend some some time
thinking about and i don't i i don't
claim to have any great answers on this
so just to be very clear about that from
the outset but i think that there's
three things that we can that we are
three options that are essentially sort
of large options on the table and that
we can think about uh the possibilities
and the sort of the the
how much we want them to be the the case
okay the first one of course is this
question about backing the syrian rebels
until they win right so there is a
notion and there's been a notion of
stepping up force and or stepping up
support for um and what we like to call
them the moderate rebels we like to sort
of have a notion that you picked the
rebels that you support and you don't
pick the others of course one of the
reasons that there was some opposition
early to putting in especially things
like anti-aircraft missiles is what
happens to the arms that you give and do
they necessarily stay with the people
that you give them to so there is a
there is a an issue here which is how
much can you actually think that you
control the sort of the forces that
you're that you're backing i think a
second issue that especially the united
states always really needs to be very
very careful of and recognize is that
there's a question of if you're if
you're trying to support one side on the
one hand it may support them at least
militarily on the other hand frankly it
may undermine their legitimacy and i
don't think that we can sort of just
turn a blind eye to that um
more importantly i have i have concerns
about sort of you know the ways in which
the sort of the recent events have have
affected this right obviously if there's
this notion in which those who you
support uh get delegitimized because
it's american support in some ways we've
only diminished the support for uh
for those who would be our allies
importantly i think we've also
diminished american support for being
willing to to do so two minutes left
okay secondly so so
so importantly i had to be starting at
six attributes okay um so importantly i
think the the the problem with that is
the ultimate leads to a keep the war
going kind of an option all right
in terms of the the result of trying to
back rebels not doing so sort of full
stop will lead to the other sides iran
hezbollah russia etc continue to do the
same thing and we end up with keeping
the war going the second option which
you hear on the table a lot and which i
find frankly is sort of
uh
okay you were right uh i finally frankly
sort of problematic is and no idea that
keeping the war going is what you want
and let me simply say that by trying to
do so first of all there will be no end
point in other words there's never a
time when the the situation is going to
get better or more easy to resolve than
it is now the spillover effects within
the region are not going to change and
and the assumptions that you're not
going to sort of you know allow the
radicals to get stronger isn't going to
change so that's not really an option
the critical issue and here i actually
seek my colleagues help is then to turn
to one of diplomatic settlement right to
really figure out a way to use what what
has just happened to try to push russia
to p and and iran to peel away from from
support for assad which would be the the
factor that would lead the sort of the
to the split within the regime that
would lead to both sides being willing
to go back to the negotiating table so
basically i think that's that's the
trick now my concern is essentially what
we've done in the meantime if we do take
chemical weapons off the table is
lowered the cost of continuing the
conflict so my fear is that this is
actually one more step towards the
continue the conflict path but that at
the end of the day what we actually have
to figure out is a way to use this to
leverage really the kind of of pressure
that it seems that russia would actually
respond to
to try to do not simply figuring out a
new equilibrium we can all live at but
figuring out a way really to get back to
the table
i'm sorry
edward snowden
now in moscow as special assistant to
president putin
has given us a highly classified
telegram
drafted by russia's chief diplomat for
the middle east georgie kennenkopf
to president putin eyes only
this telegram was sent from the russian
embassy in tehran iran
it's a long telegram i can only read to
you the main points
translated into english of course i
can't do the russian accent
begin the text
the situation is unprecedentedly
excellent
let us review it
president obama four and a half years
ago launched his major plan to
fundamentally transform
the united states of america
to achieve this he would have to take
the u.s out of its leadership role in
international security the role it has
carried on for nearly a hundred years
he has succeeded in doing so to a
remarkable degree
making him potentially the most
consequential president in american
history
of course we are delighted with this
american abdication of its leadership
at this moment the situation is
exceptionally favorable to us
when chemical weapons nerve gas was used
in syria to devastating horrifying
effect
it violated a fundamental principle of
the international state system
a system which had relied upon american
resolve
it also crossed a red line that
president obama himself had set
probably inadvertently
so obama declared that the u.s would
take military action
but the success of his own strategy for
transforming america
meant that the country was unprepared
psychologically morally politically
and militarily for such a military
option
this led president obama to explain for
several days what he was not going to do
we of course found this amusing because
the first rule of strategy
is never tell your opponent what you are
not going to do
all the while secretary of state kerry
was delivering powerful speeches on the
need for immediate forceful armed
intervention
suddenly president obama added another
knot
he was not going to decide to act
instead he would put the decision in the
hands of the congress
congress quickly read the opinion polls
which reflected the success of president
obama's approach
the american people saw no reason to get
involved
so the congress that appeared was not
going to authorize the president to take
action
as of today with the president scheduled
to address the american people this
evening
many in congress are deeply concerned
that to deny the president's request for
authorization
could be seen as tantamount to
impeachment
or at the least
turn his presidency into a lame duck
status
with over three more years to go
so from our point of view the situation
has reached an ideal stage
the united states is close to locking
itself into a permanent condition of
international ineffectiveness
the country is politically fragmented
and obama is regarded as confused and
vulnerable
thus it was a brilliant move when our
foreign minister lavrov
seized upon the offhand remark by
secretary kerry to declare that we
russia would take the lead in a
diplomatic process to place serious
weapons of mass destruction
under international control
and syria under orders from us welcomed
the idea
it has been amusing to see american
politicians of all stripes racing to
propose their acceptance
of this face-saving way out
at this moment it appears that president
obama will accept our leadership in his
speech tonight
the american president will therefore be
grateful to us and depend upon us
while at the same time we are exactly
where we want to be in that we have vast
and successful experience
in concealing and delaying all such
programs to control chemical biological
and nuclear weapons
we are of course not alone in this i am
drafting this telegram from tehran
where i have been in consultation with
the islamic revolutionary guard command
and the ayatollah
they as you know already have sent
signals to the americans that iran is
ready to negotiate comprehensively
this is because the iranians also
recognize that the americans are at this
moment confused and vulnerable
and are looking for a way to be relieved
of the crisis
so that president obama can continue
with his program of fundamentally
transforming america
the iranians have compiled an
astonishingly successful record of
delaying and deceiving the americans
about iran's relentless drive to acquire
nuclear weapons
and in this new diplomatic offensive
they will continue to do so successfully
permit me my dear vladimir vlad
to list the benefits of our current
position
first russia has replaced the us as the
arbiter and leader in international
security matters
second russia and iran are now perfectly
placed by way of our two-pronged
initiatives
to first
give president obama a non-embarrassing
way out of his dilemma
and second to get through skillful
drafting the survival of the alawite
regime in syria with syria becoming a
joint satellite of russian power and
iran's emerging shia hegemony over the
middle east
third
our two initiatives will derail the
incipient renewal of israeli-palestinian
negotiations
and here may be the most monumental
shift of all
the goal of a two-state solution for
israel and palestine is entirely in the
context of an american-led international
state system
that has structured the modern age
throughout his existence
the palestinians now
seeing the u.s retreat and accommodate
itself to our idea of international
order will come to our way of thinking
and abandon the two-state solution
fourth
we can count on china to add to our
initiative by conducting challenges to
the u.s in the east and south china seas
we therefore stand at a turning point in
history
which is nothing less than the end of
the modern age
based upon the renaissance the
reformation the enlightenment and the
westfalian state system
we the new powers have never fully
accepted the modern age with its
individualism human rights and ideal of
democracy
we know that a one-party state under
firm political control in a hierarchical
world
governed by the big regional powers is
far better as a way to control world
affairs
you dear vladimir vladimirovich have
called the collapse of the soviet union
the worst catastrophe of the 20th
century
the islamic republic of iran a true
revolutionary movement has set itself
against the established international
system since coming to power in 1979
even as it has used its status inside
that system to serve its own strategy
the people's republic of china has never
fully accepted the modern international
system it accommodated itself to it in
the post-cold war years but now has
moved into a more assertive adversarial
stance
thus we stand at the dawn of an entirely
new era
the end of the so-called modern and the
birth of a troika of power
russia iran and china
capable of dominating the entire
eurasian landmass including western
europe
which as the old geographers pointed out
means domination of the world
as a whole
respectively submitted yogi kennenkoff
well um thank you very much for uh this
opportunity and i will um deal with the
regional implications of the american
action or in action
um let me um say up front that the the
environment in the middle east
and the how the americans are operating
in intimately so america is um
there are a lot of
anti-american
sentiments in in this part of the world
in the middle east um
basically because of the american
policies over the last
decades but definitely um since the 9 11
the occupation of iraq and also
the support of the dictators
and
the support of course of the israeli
expansion and here i'm not talking about
israeli security i'm talking about
israeli expansion in the west back in
the west bank in terms of settlement
so these three factors
created a kind of environment that makes
it really um difficult for the americans
to to operate and within this
environment the americans
want to restore deterrence the
deterrence that was
broken down in uh on august 21st when uh
when the chemical weapons were used for
the first time and obama's red lines
were crossed
so
the question is how can the american
restore this kind of deterrence uh and
if this um means to be a punitive
measure that strike a few token symbols
of the syrian regime i think we most
likely are going to see the inverse
effect and and here um
all i can see that you know deterrence
would work for a short period of time
where the syrian regime would use
chemical weapon again in a matter of two
months three months and whenever they
see
feds so there will not be really
deterred in the strategic sense of of
the world
and also it would
send a clear message to the iranians
that the americans are
not really um
serious about deterrence so they think
they would think that they can across
the red lines again with relative
impunity and here i'm talking about the
the iranian nuclear program so if the
americans fail to act and act decisively
this would
probably um
kind of avoid the americans the kind of
another venture in the middle east but
it will bring america again because
israel cannot stand and stand aside and
watch the iranians developing a nuclear
capabilities and crossing the red lines
again
and doing nothing so in this case you
know i think the
the united states would be drawn into
a conflict that maybe and i'm not
advocating that maybe
acting now would avert a kind of
another big
problem in the middle east so the
israeli factor is a very
important one and also
if the
american action would be a kind of a
token one this would also send a message
to the american allies in in the region
that they cannot rely on the americans
uh this is kind of already a sense of
american is abandoning the region and
there's a kind of an american
disengagement
from the middle east
and this actually um
really weakened and demoralized the
american allies and here i'm talking
about the moderate state like jordan um
part of lebanon all of lebanon of course
and fatah movement led by mahmoud abbas
as well as saudi arabia and the dcc
but let's see what kind of scenarios
that can
materialize in in the near future the
first one if the american decide to act
like military and i'm not quite sure
that the congress would authorize that
but
the first scenario is that the american
hit and hit heart and in this case they
may
break the regime or change the balance
of forces in the civil war underground
and and this would lead
to probably the panadera box would be
opened and iran in this case would feel
that it is
the country that is threatened most by
such an an act and they might
activate hezbollah hezbollah of course
now is fighting is stretched in lebanon
and syria but it is fighting along the
syrian troops we've seen this in june
and july when hezbollah helped the
syrian troops to
regain a legal city and it was very
important strategically for both the
regime and hezbollah and there are a lot
of reports talking about
hezbollah involvement even in aleppo
around idlib and even some of them close
to iran in the south of uh of syria
so
the last thing that hezbollah wants is
to get in another war with israel
hezbollah has been
very successful in determining the sunni
troops and the sun sorry groups in
lebanon that are trying to harass
hezbollah
but if the regime
faced imminent collapse i think
hezbollah cannot deter these groups and
in this case iran and because iran is
using a proxy uh wars in the middle east
would use hezbollah to activate and open
another fee another front with israelis
and and this will um probably reshuffle
the whole card in the middle east
so this is a very important thing but
also the iranians can amount it can
carry out the kind of proxy militant
attacks in the gulf and they have the
capabilities to do that and they can't
do it but
but you know so far they are not doing
this so lebanon would be destabilized
again and also the day after scenario we
have to think of of this if the regime
faces or is going to face a kind of
collapse
the iranians would think of a kind of
reinsurgency and this is um some this is
what their bill uh have been doing now
and maybe iran would support their
troops and their people working for them
in order to
degrade the capability the military
capabilities of the uh
of the um
of the rebels um
uh also a decisive show of american
force in the region would assure the
american allies and would also
invigorate
the rebels and here there are bulls
actually we can't lump them under one in
one and one basket here
if you look at the opposition in syria
and i myself have done a lot of work in
that and you can't really think of a
kind of a unifying monolithic force even
al-qaeda itself is is divided in iraq we
have the islamic state for el iraq and
shem led by al-baghdadi and the nostra
front lit by el julianil giuliani um
he gave the oath of allegiance to
zawahiri who is the ultimate leader of
al-qaeda and
ultimately the rule is for nusra and net
for the islamic state in iraq so there
are a lot of things here
uh to be taken into account and then on
the other hand we have the moderate
forces and this is where the americans
have failed actually against the
american state stated policy to to
strengthen and beef up
the uh the moderate for forces but
over the last two years and a half the
americans have done little to uh really
beef up and strengthening these uh these
forces uh
also the opposition now is thinking of
i mean here i'm talking about some of
the opposition groups they think of um
kind of doing another sahaba sahaba is
the iraqi revival revivals in 2007
remember when david petraeus came up
with the idea of the search and then
abducted
in iraq he started this kind of
revival meaning they fight the the fight
al-qaeda so there are some rebels among
the the opposition in in syria now is
trying to join forces in order to fight
al-qaeda as well as fight the regime
itself and i think these are the the
elements that the americans as well as
the american allies in the region need
to think of working with uh also
civilians in in syria they need
they need to see an action international
action
you cannot guess people like this we i
i'm not talking that about killing 100
000 people it's okay but killing 14 or
1500
by chemical weapon is is is okay so but
they need to be they need to see a kind
of international okay
international um reaction to what
happened also there's a scenario of uh
um of the failure to act and and this
would be i think the um
maybe a catastrophe for the americans in
the region it would further uh
demoralize american allies it would
further actually um
kind of
strengthen the iranians hezbollah and
this
uh this axis uh so um
here's
there let me just conclude with this
note that it would be
a different outcome as um
if an attack whatever the kind of attack
is accompanied with a strategy and the
strategy here i'm talking about working
meticulously in order to strengthen the
um
the
moderate
groups in in syria to continue their
work uh but also to work with the
international community in order to use
the attack if if it materialize and to
push the syrian regime to go to the
geneva ii or actually reconvene geneva
ii or
do some political framework political
process then thank you very much
so
so on the 29th of august the british
parliament voted to block
uk involvement in military action
against the syrian regime it's a close
vote
it was blocked by 13 votes
and that's the first time since 1782
that a british prime minister
lost a vote to go to war
1782
you'll remember
we won't go into that
according to the polls three quarters of
brits believe that the mps were right to
reject uk military action in syria
two-thirds of those polled didn't care
if it affected u.s uk relations
so why did britain vote against the use
of military force
first the ghosts of iraq
were all scarred by iraq
the vote in parliament wasn't a vote
about syria it was a vote about iraq
and syria is not iraq
the legacy of the iraq war
has been a loss of confidence in
politicians and their ability to make
the right decisions
it's been a distrust
of intelligence that dodgy dossier that
got us into the iraq war
and also general pessimism about
intervention
that no matter how hard we try and a
matter of good intent
things don't go the way that we hope
in iraq we contributed to bringing about
a civil war
we upset the balance of power in the
region
and then disengaged
in such a way that left the perception
that iraq has become a client's state of
iran
the second factor was that the public is
much more influential now than it was
before
the public has much more access to
information
party politics in britain is in decline
and the public keep demanding
evidence-based decision-making they're
no longer satisfied with gut reactions
so the british prime minister failed to
build a convincing case for intervention
the public asked hard questions
we did nothing in the face of one
hundred thousand syrians killed
why should we do something about one
thousand more killed
how will these proposed military strikes
stop the killing
yes there's evidence it was a chemical
weapons attack but what evidence is
there that assad himself ordered the
attack
and if we did attack what would be the
unintended consequences
we kill innocent people
create more anti-western sentiment
people argue that syria is not our war
it's a civil war it's a proxy war we
don't want to get involved
and some said it's illegal illegal to
strike we don't have the agreements of
the un security council
so the public were debating these
questions raising these questions and
the british prime minister wasn't able
to build a convincing argument
so where has the uk vote left britain
the uk has always prided itself in its
internationalism
since the end of world war ii
the uk has stood with the us
shoulder-to-shoulder to contribute to
international security
and to benefit from international order
so the vote has raised questions of
britain's role in the world
and the next day after the vote
there was a sense that
what happens in syria does affect us
whether we like it or not
we live in a connected world
weak states can get hold of nasty
weapons
and we've got transnational
international terrorism
what's happening in syria is a massive
humanitarian crisis
120 000 people killed
a third of all syrians are now displaced
and this summer i visited syrian
refugees in jordan and iraq
living in a state of limbo
the spillover is affecting the stability
of our allies
and we've got young brits
leaving britain and going off to syria
to fight
many of them will come back
made more extreme by that experience
so what are the consequences if we do
nothing
about the situation in syria
syria is not going to go away
if we don't punish those
responsible for the use of chemical
weapons how will we deter them
or others
from using them in the future
the conflict in syria is perceived in
the region to be empowering iran
and there's concern that iran might fear
that there'll be no consequences for
pursuing
a nuclear weaponization program
israel may feel that it can't rely on
the west
gulf allies may look to others for
security guarantees
which might involve them giving more
support to extreme jihadi groups
russia and china filling the vacuum
influencing the new world
order non-state actors such as al qaeda
and hezbollah are becoming more powerful
and it's not an exaggeration to look at
these things and say the middle east
may be heading towards a regional war
so that raises the question of how
should the u.s respond
intervention should be aimed at ending
the killing
brokering a peace agreement
and stopping the spillover into
neighbouring countries
threat of force by the us
and use of it
should contribute to that overall
strategy
stopping the killing brokering a peace
agreement stopping the spillover
it should not just be a compromise
between those who want to stay out of
syria
and those who want to bring about regime
change
so the u.s needs to strengthen its
diplomacy on three tracks
one level u.s and russia
to try and reach consensus on an
acceptable outcome to the conflict in
syria
there's common ground
there's areas where russia and the us
can seek consensus particularly on not
wanting to see the growth
and spread of jihadi groups
second track is with regional powers
to try and stop the arming of different
sides in a proxy war
with the election of president rouhani
in iran
it's a new opening it's a new
opportunity
and iran should be given a seat at the
table
and at the third track
between
elements of the regime and elements of
the opposition
there are moderate elements
semi-moderate elements on both sides
who can be brought into a political
settlement
regarding chemical weapons there's an
opportunity for diplomatic response
the un security council resolution
condemning the use of chemical weapons
that looks a possibility now
the international criminal court could
be used to investigate those responsible
for the attack
if assad commits to disposing of
stockpiles and to allow in the
inspectors
it's also stopping the escalation of the
fighting
it will be difficult to get a un
resolution which then
authorizes the use of force for
international military action
if the chemical weapons are not dealt
with in that way but it's something that
we should continue to press with
now the world's not going to stop
presenting us with these ethical
problems and moral conundrums
just because we're tired of war
the legacy of the iraq war shouldn't be
isolationism
but it should be searching for sensible
strategies for confronting the
challenges that we face thank
you thank you
well thanks a lot frank for inviting me
here to this prestigious panel
and
to speak in front of this esteemed
audience i'll try to speak from here
because i want to keep it as informal as
as i can
and actually i do not have much to say
after all what has been said and
especially after the
lengthy debate that has been going on
here in the states and elsewhere
a fair amount of information and a fair
amount of opinions have been circulated
to the uh american public and to the
internet to the international community
but i will try i'll try to be brief and
i'll try to raise a few
points
my first point will be
as an egyptian an arab and a muslim will
be to to kind of try to convey to you
how we feel about the
possibility of military intervention in
syria
i have to tell you that
we in the region we have we have
developed a kind of intrinsic skepticism
towards any
u.s
attempt to military intervene in our
region
our our experiences
with the military of the us has not been
pleasant
whether in the in the near past or in
the or before this with the whole
western military
so even the most staunch supporters
in syria for u.s military interventions
are not doing this because they actually
trust that the us has a plan or actually
trust the u.s good intentions they're
just doing it out of despair
it's like
okay so we hit the bottom what is going
to be worse than this so let the u.s
maybe this will create different
dynamics but none of them none of them
not a single person if you ask him
personally will tell you yes i believe
the us has good intentions in syria
this might be shocking but this is the
truth
history
in our region is
not favorable of any uh
of this kind of u.s
actions
second point is about the strike itself
for me and for many people i know
and actually i think it's pretty logic
that it is not morally unjustifiable
this kind this strike which is limited
surgical which is only targeting
chemical weapons
chemical we believe and everybody should
believe that
chemical weapons are evil because they
kill
so if you just
if you just okay removed chemical
weapons out of the table and leave
killing
then you are not doing good there is no
moral justification for intervention
based on getting rid of
chemical weapons alone
there has to be an end to this suffering
well my third point is about okay what
if the president obama goes tonight and
declares that he is going to strike
syria anyway whether with congress
congressional approval or not
then there are a number of points that
we have to think about the first one
will be what is the operational
objective of such a strike how can you
declare a winner
when and how will the president obama or
asset come and say i am victorious
mission accomplished
for asset he made this equation pretty
clear his media machine has already done
the job and they are portraying this as
part of the overall international
conspiracy led by the us against the
anti-imperialism represented in himself
so this means whatever the u.s strikes
however long it might be however damage
it can have can happen to him as long as
he stays then he can declare himself
winner and this is very much
uh
it's not very strange in our region that
okay so maybe your troops are heavily
damaged but you stay then you're the
winner
and actually
his troops believe in this and his
followers and supporters believe in this
so if he stays if the military strike
happens and he stays which is
basically the case because president
obama is promising a strike that is
limited and is only targeting chemical
weapons then he is a winner and for the
chemical weapons he actually made a very
smart
move with the russians he so it's
totally out of the table now so what is
the operational objective what is u.s
actually seeking
second thing related to the strike
what is the impact of such a strike on
the war itself on the battles in the
ground on syria
i cannot see if
by the description of
president obama and secretary kerry of
such a strike
a possibility to change the current
balance except by
maybe
potentially by neutralizing the syrian
air force
this can happen because this this is not
very easy but it's doable because the uh
syrian air force depend on like 20
military airports
actually uh the seven of them are only
active so it can they can be targeted
and if they have the millage of the air
force syrian regime air force air is
neutralized then this will can this can
affect uh and give
positive
give have positive impact over the rebel
side especially in the northern area and
maybe in the in the cities especially in
the cities of aleppo and idlib
but will the is this the case i don't
know and i don't think anybody knows
because the president and secretary
kerry are are not telling us and nobody
is telling us what is actually the plan
the third point related to the strike is
how does it affect and influence the
course for geneva ii
we had we have had a joint
statement by
the u.s and
nine other countries on the margin of
g20 saying that geneva 2 is the actual
uh
is the current solution is the solution
to be followed political solution
through uh geneva communique
so what impact does this strike will
have will this strike have on geneva 2
if this
might my answer to this if it it's only
targeting chemical weapons then it
doesn't have anything to do with geneva
too nothing is going to change okay so
the regime will still have its his
powers his troops he will have will
still have iranian backing russian
backing
and he still controls damascus that
controls hans he still controls whole of
the
of the coast area
so and the opposition remained
fragmented unorganized lack of
leadership lack of armament lack of
regular backing from any uh any single
country so the situation does not really
change so what if
if if this strike is just singled out
as it is as declarations of the
president and his foreign minister
secretary of state
then it will not have any change on
geneva 2.
my final point here which is about
does the u.s have options
did the u.s have options we have for 30
months 31 months actually
and 120 000 people killed
and
the us is not actually moving in the
right trajectory
everybody
who is following this file will know
that the us diplomacy and u.s political
tools have not been been used to stop
the killing
the objective here
at least from my point of view and from
syrian point of view and egyptian and
the arab and muslim point of view and
humanitarian point of view will be to
stop the killing not to restore american
leadership not to
go regain credibility
the objective must be stop the blood
shed stop the killing which is only
achievable through
a controlled transition it's not
achievable through toppling just
stopping military operation toppling
asset and it's not achievable through
just
leaving the war continue now there has
to be a controlled transition how the us
can achieve this
strategy
strategy it's a word that we all repeat
and we all talk about but it's i did i
did not see it diplomacy diplomacy is
something that i mean the the
u.s state department is huge they have a
lot of resources and uh
a lot of smart diplomats very smart ones
and but they are not really in action
they are not really in action and what
we see with russia now
is very evident that maybe there can be
a political solution the russians just
moved because there has been some kind
of like
a threat a carrot a stick but they do
not see
they do not see the carrot
to actually move further there has to be
okay
okay so i'll just i'll i'll conclude
here so
uh
the us can can actually move can
actually talk to its adversaries and its
friends the u.s has kept silent when the
saudi arabia and qatar were actually
competing over the uh on the syrian file
and their competition was was doing a
lot of harm to the syrian opposition and
to the syrian population the the u.s is
keeping silent wine when turkey turkey's
borders are heavily infiltrated by
chechnyans and afghans and pakistanis
who
flood who come from everywhere and the
fighters who come from everywhere even
from the uk as emma just pointed out who
and cross the borders and establish
daesh or nusrah or any any other entity
that is fighting in inside syria and the
us can talk to russia and they can talk
to russia and russia okay you can think
of putin as an evil leader an evil
dictator somebody who was trying to
restructure the world in his own terms
okay but this is not the case here at
the end of the day putin will have some
rational calculations to make and no i
didn't see i didn't see over the past
two years any attempt to have
putin change his mind
thank you
i must thank my colleagues that they
have actually abided to the tight time
frame that i gave them and i must also
mention that we of course knew that the
international security studies program
actually has
the best
connections here on campus but charlie
of course you surprised us with how far
they actually reached
we now open the panel
for question and answers and i must say
also
as tough as i was on my colleagues with
regard to the time that i gave them i
must also urge you in this case to keep
your questions short we would like to
have as many questions as possible to
talk about as many aspects as possible
in the next hour or so that we have left
so i would ask you to refrain from
longer statements and really put your
question to the point i open the forum
now
i see a question over there
i'd like to ask professor hill if he
could comment more on that
of course it's exaggerated um for effect
but underlying it i think is um
uh
some of the facts of big power rivalries
and and uh
life in the international scene and i
think
also in the washington political
situation
it is fundamentally that the country the
u.s the american
people are not prepared to get into this
the polls show that
the congress reads the polls
uh the president
has been taking the country in that
direction
so that in any kind of ordinary
calculation of
the political factors involved the
congress would not authorize would not
give the president the authorization he
is asking for
at the same time
in the last couple of days it's become
clear
that this is severely um
painful in the congress
apart from those out on the fringe in
both parties painful
you don't want to i think emma has
brought
this up in terms of parliament and the
british vote
you don't want to
so severely damage a presidency
as a no vote would do
turning away from the presidents and the
secretary of state's very very powerful
arguments for action
so
the
the scramble is on for what can we do to
get out of this
and the answer has come forward
in the idea of
uh an agreement
an understanding by which syria would
turn its
chemical biological and other weapons
over to
an international
control system
and that's what's i think almost
certainly going to happen
so that the president will make a tough
speech tonight
he will talk about the necessity of
action
but he will grasp as to a life-saving
ring
that way out
and then that will delay the process
and
we know and this was i think truly
stated in the in the cable
that uh the iranians particularly
uh others in the region and the russians
also
have made a brilliant diplomatic record
in manipulating such
initiatives in ways that buy more time
for them
so that
this
if you had if i had to make a guess
about this
it's going to fade away
and in six months we'll be back where we
were
maybe in may or april and it will
tonight will be the moment when there'll
be a lot of heavy talk but it will
begin to be diffused
there was a question over there
got ourselves involved in civil wars
where we shouldn't have gotten involved
we've lost troops and that no matter
what they say
we're
about oh
the us is great they're coming in we
don't have any support from any other
countries in this we don't have nato
support
we don't have the support of the hague
saying yes let's take this guy up on war
crimes
it doesn't make sense
but correct me if i'm wrong
somebody actually wants to take that out
i mean i'll respond very briefly to
because i don't disagree with you so
there's not much correction to be done
the one thing i would say is i think
there's
what we also have to remember is there's
a spectrum here right so what's been
interesting and this came open in
discussions and i think muhammad has
also raised this nicely um you know this
idea that because we don't want to get
so embroiled in another war that we keep
sort of this mantra of no american boots
on the ground right and i i realize the
pain of having been an american boot on
the ground but but that that i actually
think frankly if i if i'm arab is
insulting right the idea that it's okay
to come in and strike and you'll you can
kill others but it's it's not going to
strike you and and and it's and and the
sort of the no quote this sort of idea
of a quite so limited strike that it
doesn't get the reverberations is also
problematic so i would agree with you i
mean in in my in my mind it is either
sort of the don't strike notion right
and
find other ways to try to pressure and
come up with real sort of diplomatic
solutions which i think and and here i
entirely agree with my colleagues that
ending the killing should be this top
priority and not sort of this question
about sort of restoring american
leadership i mean you can restore
american leadership by ending the
killing right that's the other part of
it um but i would say that that's that's
that's sort of the the the kind of the
major goal and this idea of something
that's that's limited that that keeps
american boots off the ground and
therefore not your experience is
problematic as is the sort of the
sort of the more potentially kind of um
full-blown work so can i just add in
this just
one thing a very quick thing is um you
know just to avoid the kind of any
unintended mispresentation on their
upside i don't think that their upside
is united behind any any position
uh we've seen
the americans
moved in libya for instance and it was
they were held
by
a majority of the arabs they that was
the first time uh i i noticed a kind of
an arab acceptance and here i'm not
talking about all arabs but like
a considerable segment of arab societies
and judging from the social media
facebooks and also the articles written
in different
um journals
and the newspapers so there was the
first time that we um we see arabs who
say what maybe the american force can be
used in
an enlightened way and here's in
quote-unquote
i mean i disagree with any notion that i
said that they are against
all four
i think you know it's not either or i
think even
there are a lot of arabs who would love
to see okay and here i'm not talking
about regimes by the way regime that our
pro-american regime i'm talking about
really activists in
in the arab revolution that are
uprising etc
they see that you know
for all those who make the case against
american intervention and
they can't really put an end to the
killing to the killing machines are
operated by not only assad but also in
regional policy i'm talking about iran
so if the americans can move and do
something to neutralize this machine i i
think is there is
many people who would say um good job
and well some many people will say
it's not a good job it's a kind of it
would reinforce a kind of
a kind of
a conspiracy you know as muhammad says
like um
correctly and accurately that
many people with no matter what the
americans going to do in the middle east
it would be seen as bad things
and when i read some articles in the
newspapers so one of the one one of the
arguments that you know since the
americans say yes for a bomb against
syria it means it's good for israel so
this kind of logic you know conditions
some people would say no to any american
action in the middle east but here
one more but just not to mispresent the
arab side i think there are a lot of
division among the arabs as to
what they expect from the americans
there was one question there in the
middle
uh
the absence of like serious sustained
action in syrian life and flight worst
war for the united states by risking
strategic miscalculation on the part of
the us's adversary so i mean mike china
is seeing that the u.s having stated the
red line and not seriously forced to
take aggressive action against real
american interests you know say japan or
taiwan and then invite greater u.s war
than what we're contemplating now and
he's that damage already done when
secretary kerry describes the
contemplated
the answer to what i hear you say is
is yes and i think in all of this
wherever you want to come out on it
the missing
dimension of the
debate is the larger global
international system international
community
international order
big power relationship dimension to it
we are always trying to drill down into
the
the fine points of any problem and if
you deal with that fine point then you
can move on to the next one but there's
a larger framework here
that is immense
and it's one that you can call
the international system
it's been going on for a long time
the united states and a few others have
been
the stewards of it
and when the u.s began to pull away from
its role
now a few years ago
you could see if you're attuned to these
things diplomatically in public
commentaries you can see that in every
part of the world
countries governments begin to make
their rearrangements
because they begin to say well the
americans are not going to be around the
americans are not going to be counted on
the america's not going to bother us
so we've got to make our accommodations
with others
so there's been a lot of deal making
going on already
going back some years now
and that's beginning to reshape the
entire
profile
of internet what the un calls you know
the maintenance of international peace
and security
and it also
in the cable telegram that i read from
is not crazy
then you can see this in some of the
articles by
really profound intellectuals in china
and russia
beginning to talk about this is the end
of an order this is the end of an order
that really has been holding the world
some in some sense together for
generations and if it's ending then what
are we going to do about it where will
we find our role
so these big issues i think have got to
be in the back of our minds as we
approach these choices
charles if you just allow a follow-up on
that in this case so so you say in this
case that there is an international
system that might suffer there one of
the questions that i might put towards
the panel is in this case
can we actually say that this
international system which as you might
say in this case has broken down
recently or is on the way off game has
it actually worked in the middle east
has the current configuration of power
in this case which all of course was
supported for a long time and by the us
actually has it worked
i respond to this because actually i
wanted to
in in a sense in response to both i
totally agree with you hussain that
there's a wide range of opinion and we
should we shouldn't characterize the
arabs as was one thing on the other hand
it also strikes me that there are um
that we have to remember that first of
all
generally there's a widespread of i
think sort of set of arabs who would say
that the international system had not
actually worked very well from in the
past and here this is where it's sort of
the basis of kind of the anti-american
sentiment that we were talking about
before you can see it in polls and you
can see it in a lot of places and
attitudes towards why is america sort of
shoring up our dictators and saying it
likes democracy and all sorts of things
i mean have been you know way preceded
there the arab uprisings okay so so i
think we can't forget that and we also
similarly can't forget that we no longer
we're living in a world where there's no
longer private debates we can't have a
debate
even at yale and say you know we need to
make sure america stays the leader of
the world and we maintain our sort of
our place in in order and don't think
that it's going to be picked up and
somebody in in egypt is going to hear it
and syria is going to say see we told
you so and that's why bashar is our sort
of our our defense against those
imperialists and so we can't it's an
interesting issue right charlie because
we may want to have on the table and
certainly i mean if it's in the back of
our minds i think it in a sense it needs
to stay there because when we have these
debates about what this does to american
order even if we think american order is
great for the world
there's an audience out there that's
hearing that that doesn't necessarily
think it's great for the world and it
doesn't necessarily sort of share those
those goals so i think we have to
remember we've got multiple audiences
that hear all of these debates and that
while there's a variation in opinion
about something like you know should
should the americans sort of strike
syria and what's the sort of the impact
of that and even sort of what should be
sort of the regional order that there
are some things in which there's pretty
a lot of widespread agreement on and the
fact that the american order hasn't
really helped arabs generally is one of
those things i would say it's a it's a
fairly sort of you know
it's like americans thinking democracy
is better than communism maybe there's a
few communists out there but just
generally we're pretty we're pretty
agreed on it
this is a huge significance and this is
not an american order the united states
has been
the most active leader of defending the
order but this order
is a world order it's agreed to
has been across
150 years at least
it is the international state system
this is an order of states in the middle
east it has not worked well
but every part of the arab world is a
state
the arab league's name is the arab
league of states
the
negotiations between the israelis and
the palestinians is over a two-state
solution
and if you take away this system
what system will replace it
that's where we're talking about
something that's been going on for
really three centuries
and if it goes
then what is going to come after
is not going to be pretty
uh that was for muhammad
just then i actually give back the
question yeah just a very brief very
very brief comment
for what it means what the american and
what the international order means in
the arab world and what the american
order or the american leadership mean
for the arab world actually most of the
of the governments and the arab world
are friendly to the us and this and
actually they have they tried to sustain
the relationships with the u.s as much
as
they can with few exceptions but this
means to
the but when we when we ask any u.s
president american president about what
are the us interests in the arab world
on the middle east it will be first
security of israel second will be secure
oil resources which if we think of it
from the flip side from the other side
it means okay keep palestine neglected
and forget about the atrocities and
second thing keep
using and abusing our nature resources
because you the americans want to be
rich and our countries have to remain
poor this is how it is
it it can be perceived maybe some people
have are more sophisticated are more
able to build a better understanding of
the situation are more able to partner
with the us but the message that the lay
person the average person in the streets
and uh in the arab world
they get it like this
that the us government's leadership
means security of israel which keep
palestine occupied and forget about it
and keep utilizing our resources and for
the international
system
uh there is like okay it's very it's uh
the uh we can actually speak about this
and and about how the us actually did
not really respect the international uh
regulations and international uh system
regulation especially the un many times
especially in the
in our part of the world and
one of the most used example is is the
toefl ii the uh security council
resolution of 242 for the
uh occupation occupied territories uh
palestinian territories by israel
this this uh security council resolution
has been there for more than 40 years
and the u.s is has never actually tried
to implement it and that's it means a
lot for the
more questions um let me take this over
there
uh you've mentioned several possible
scenarios uh for becoming europe too
what are the possible implications of
these scenarios for the territorial
integrity of syria and for the stability
of development
you want me to answer that okay
others are also welcome to join in
in in some ways right i mean there this
gets back to this question about um if
the they could there's sort of continue
the war there's the sort of beef up the
rebels and let them win and then there's
the try to get to the sort of the table
as quickly as possible and frankly in
terms of the regional stability which
actually is is
been undermined and will continue to be
undermined as long as the conflict in
syria goes on then getting some kind of
an of an end
to as quickly as possible i think is the
imperative so it's not just about
stopping the killing in in syria it's
actually in some ways about stopping the
possibilities and the expansion of
killing killing elsewhere and so
in my mind the third scenario is is sort
of optimal in that sense i mean and this
the continuing the war frankly is the
worst scenario in that sense even though
there's people who seem to think that
you can't let them win you can't let
them lose and and then the the question
of again arming the rebels i didn't
explain it very well when i was talking
but you know the arming the rebels if
you got to the rebels winning if you're
willing to really arm them and really
make you know really sort of change the
balance right and and that's that's huge
because that's not just about changing
the balance between the regime and and
the rebels it really is also recognizing
that you know iran will in and russia
and others will play a role in this um
you know that requires i think frankly a
level of commitment we're probably not
willing to make um if that was made if
there were that kind of outcome i mean
that and and quickly that could lead
also i think to sort of helping to
secure the regional regional balance in
the regional power but in my mind the
best the best scenario is trying to find
you know the levers in the institute to
really move the move the the player to
the table i actually don't think that's
easy when i said i would actually
welcome my colleagues sort of input on
this i really meant it i mean i think
it's much easier to say i'll get them to
the table than it is actually to figure
out how to do that
there's really only one scenario
it's an unfortunate one but it's a fact
of the region
and that is that
we the outside world and those in
the arab world largely
uh telling themselves and telling us for
decades and decades and decades that
they were stable
and unified
had only one policy
there was only one arab nation
and the only problem was israel
and then a few years ago a rock was
lifted
and the difference between what is
happening there now and what was
happening there 10 years ago
is gigantic because when the rock was
lifted it turned out to be a big lie
that underneath the rock were
innumerable factions and forces
that instantly were at each other's
throats
within the region within the faith
and what you have now
in across the region
sometimes openly and sometimes below the
surface but about the burst through
are really three civil wars going on
within the arab islamic world
and one is sunni versus shia
and the other very consequential is
between those
however they
muslim they may be however they take
their politics who want to be states in
the international state system and those
who want
to destroy it and take it over and put
another system in effect such as al
qaeda
and the third civil war
which has been at least momentarily
crushed
is the arab spring
and that is a young youthful
movement that is none of the old gang
parties neither the muslim brotherhood
nor the old militaries who have come out
on the streets hopeful wanting an open
society
wanting possibilities for a better life
in a better economy
and they came out and we welcomed them
around the world in january 2011
and very quickly they were
crushed
they're not gone they're going to come
back
but they now it's back to the old guys
again
the old dictators and the old militaries
and the old islamists
and when you have civil wars they don't
end in
conferences in geneva
they end by somebody winning the war
and nobody can stop that we can round
the edges do humanitarian operations
maybe something about the chemical
weapons but we can't stop these civil
wars somebody's going to win it it's
going to be like the north and the south
and the american civil war
somebody's going to win it and it's
going to take a long time for it to
happen although maybe this is an
occasion to to to spell this out to our
audience clearly what would be in this
case a positive or in this case the
least least in this case the least
negative
outcome that we could expect in this
case out of out of the civil war charlie
of course you just said uh there must
always be a winner but i remember for
instance uh when we take a look at the
civil war that was raging in the former
yugoslavia there was a process that
ended in the date and peace agreement
that was a conference that that that in
effect ended the civil war and that
ended the civil war in the is that with
the establishment eventually in this
case off by now four
new countries is that something that we
might also see in syria
i think the best outcome is for the war
to be fought to a point where neither of
these various sides can conclude that it
can win but that's already the case
almost uh that
that's not impossible i think that's
what happened in in bosnia right the
point was you know the croats said i
can't live under the serbs the serbs
said i can't live under the bosniaks the
bosniak says i can't live on any of
these people and i'm willing to die
before i will be ruled by them and
there's something of that going on in
the middle east now so at a certain
point exhaustion
murderous exhaustion uh can bring about
a conclusion but we're not there yet
how's that
thank you i mean
all i want to add to this is that the
the conflict is not only within syria
it's it's over syria
and this brings the regional actors and
then this is very important and that's
why
i think it is i cannot see in any part
of the of the
of the civil war right now and syria can
can win in the in the foreseeable future
uh because it doesn't matter how much
the iranians have this odis will step in
and give money and
and arms so
it's going to continue it's like you
know keeping the ball in there like
without going down it's going to
continue for a while unless there's
an agreement among the actors that
underpin the civil war and here i'm
talking about this yeah because we've
seen like when the russians said
we will that the syrian regime can hand
in hand over the the chemical weapon as
i said yes so he you know who called the
shots in in
in this
in in syria i said i really doubt that i
mean i think that the iranians
are more important and the russians are
more important because you know once in
bhutan said
okay let's just do something about the
chemical weapon i mean the first one
to come in public and say yes this is a
good
deal is assad himself so
that's why maybe i have like a little
disagreement over whether we can do it
in geneva or not i think a framework
that is an agreed upon framework among
the regional actors and among the
international actors that have staked in
this union is a preconditions for
uh for stability and at least it can
ameliorate the civil war even if it
cannot in that
emma and then
i open the floor again for questions
yes i also have slight disagreements
with charlie on this i mean i don't
think when you look at the civil war
that is taking place inside syria
it is not simple by any stretch the
imagination it is not sunni sheer it
doesn't break down that easily
the reasons why people support the
regime for some it's existential fear
fear of the alternative
so the regime does have supporters who
are sunnis it has supporters who are
christians
obviously has strong alawite support but
the opposition also has supporters who
are sunni supporters who are christians
supporters who are alawite
so it's really really not clear-cut
yes
most civil wars do end
when one side defeats another
but not all civil wars end that way
and with syria
yes
parties are getting exhausted
not totally exhausted but exhaustion can
come
or there's things that we can do to help
bring on that exhaustion
so as i was mentioning before at one
level it needs to be an agreement
between
russia and the us and it can't just be
i said must go assad must stay it cannot
just be this agreement or this sorry
this argument over assad
no dialogue is going to start if that is
the starting point so it has to be how
do we stop the killing
so then with the regional parties who
are fueling this conflict it's a proxy
war that's going on
how do we get them to stop arming
paying
equipping
the different sides of different
fighters
a lot of it it goes back to iran it goes
back to the islamic revolution
fear of iran's expansion influence in
the region
whether it's true or not is another
matter but that's the perception of it
some of these countries feel they lost
iraq to iran
so it's a power struggle that's playing
out
over iran people can break it down and
say it's sunni shia it's more to do with
iran versus saudi versus turkey
so if we can try and stop
that proxy war that's going on how do we
try and stop that because we produce
a vision of an outcome that is not one
side wins one side loses that's the
existential fear
it's a vision
of an inclusive
settlement
inside syria
a settlement that's acceptable
russia us acceptable to the regional
powers acceptable to the people who live
in syria so this cannot be one side
winning and the other side losing
has to move away from the zero sum if
there's any hope
of stopping this just
contagion spreading through the region
over there in the back
yes
i was wondering if the panel could
outline
what specific national interests
american national interests are at stake
in syria and what possible methods do we
have available to us in order to pursue
those so for instance if we were to
attack syria in pursuit of what interest
would we do that and what would a good
outcome be at the same time if we were
to do nothing that's also a strategy and
what would and how would that
help us secure our national interests
the national interest is pretty much as
i
have said before
and that is
that
what happens in syria
could
tip the balance
so that the entire region
would come under one hegemon
probably iran
and or because iran is an adversary of
the international system
the entire region would drop out of
world order
and if that's the case that would be i
think almost a fatal blow
to
world order as we have known it for a
long time
and the u.s has been
has been the policeman of this
so when we see the politicians saying we
can't be the policeman
uh there's no other policeman
it's like saying uh we're not going to
have any policemen in new haven
and then you can say well as long as the
gunfire is not on my block i don't care
but there's a bad part of town if
they're not policemen the bad part of
town is going to get bigger and bigger
and bigger
and that's the fundamental american
interest
can i add on something to that which is
i it cannot be forgotten that that
this is
charlie's right i mean the the fear is
that the region goes under hajiman that
is not our friend and that's you know
iran slash russia etc
it matters to us and muhammad mentioned
this earlier because israel's there and
because oil is there i mean we we
shouldn't shy away from recognizing that
we particularly care in this part of the
region in fact we particularly care in
there more than we do about north africa
for example also part of the arab muslim
world but not necessarily so important
for us strategically as we do and what's
happening with essentially borderline
states to to israel you know pipeline
states too and and and and states are
very close and and and bigger actually
at the end of the day than the gulf
states that are nearby so that's that's
something to recognize that that's part
of what drives the grand concern um i
one could argue much to the detriment of
the region for for decades but that's
part of what what drives us
at the very
um
okay well uh
for me i mean apart from any diplomatic
diplomatic talk asset cannot stay
this is this is one thing that has to be
said and very clearly asset cannot stay
but the point is that negotiations and
the way to lead that the ways that lead
to
an outcome cannot start by saying this
this is a point that is asset cannot
stay this is a done deal uh no
um i would say like uh
most more than 40 50 percent of the
population cannot actually stay in a
country where which is uh in which assad
is the ruler maybe he still has the
support of like 30 percent of the
population but the the this 30 percent
of the population actually do not look
at him personally they just seek
security most of them at least most of
them seek security there are parts
parts of them who have like personal
interests and personal leverages and
even regional
they are the guardians of the regional
interests that have to be
negotiated upon so having having said
that there is a solution there is a
political solution what is the solution
in diplomacy and in any poli in any kind
of politics international relations is
based on like you have to have options
you have to tell every
any country that you are dealing with
okay i'm negotiating this means that you
take something and you give something
it's very easy so okay what is the us of
what did the us offer russia what did
the u.s offer for like uh the regime in
syria the parts of the regime who can
actually be part of the new transition
what did the u.s offer even iran i know
i know that this is like a very hot
topic and very controversial but it's
what did the us do to do this and on the
other hand what did the us do to affect
their leverage so for example iraq
this is a country that has been invaded
by the u.s this is a country that their
military and their government and
everything there was almost established
by the us and the us does not have
leverage on iraq the u.s cannot actually
tell iraq you are the main supply route
for asset if iraq it stops closes its
airfield for like the planes that come
from iran to syria then assad will have
no very limited supply but the u.s is
not doing this so the u.s there is and
here i agree with professor josh hill
that the u.s has a severe problem in
leadership the the us does not exercise
its leadership with with with with any
kind of a vision in the region
this has to be tackled there is a
solution a possible solution it's very
difficult very complicated needs a lot
of work but this is this is the world
and nothing is easy
with with respect to the very narrow
issue of chemical weapons
and regardless of whether that issue is
even
worth solving
is it plausible that the negotiated
settlement of that issue has has
surfaced in the last day or two
could be effective in resolving that
relation
it can be but it will take a very very
very long time it's a very complicated
logistics and political issue
and the people who are offering to do it
are not the people that you would buy a
used car from
so
what would you do
or not
well i think politically practically
speaking it will be taken up yes you
can't not take it up
but as we do and this is true of
several many
uh diplomatic uh initiatives and
negotiations in and around and of and
for the middle east
you find very shortly that the other
side is playing games with you
they are
wanting to postpone a meeting
they want to move it from geneva to
istanbul
they will be giving different stories to
the press one day and another day
and pretty soon you're you're tangled up
and nuts so
it can happen if if this the side that
is
the representing the international
community will hold the other side to
serious negotiations but we have not
done that but if you start on that
little issue
would that process help everybody work
on other issues what's going to happen
is that
if
we will accept this proposal
to turn the weapons over to the
international community
there will be a meeting set forth two
weeks from now
uh that'll not get anywhere but will be
it was important to me then it'll be
another one set and that will be
postponed and pretty soon we're gonna be
down by the end of november to it's not
going anywhere
so then somebody's gonna say
in the congress it's not going anywhere
so now you have to strike
and go to the u.n
and russia will veto it well that speaks
to our limitations right but if we start
an international group of russian
syrians egyptians iranians americans
whoever the hell they all are
to try to start to talk about the
chemical issue
is that as a practical matter because
we're all human beings
is that going to lead to broader
discussions that might be helpful
all i want to say about this is that
the failure to acknowledge the interest
of different players have only
complicated the issue so it's not about
the even the civil war in syria it's the
symptoms of
uh of the root cause of the the problem
here the the class of strategies in in
the middle east the iranians have been
using
what is happening in syria in the
context of a war of attrition with the
american strategy and america has a
problem here it's kind of on the one
hand
big i think america can live with the
nuclear iran uh based on deterrence but
the israelis think that an iranian a
nuclear a nuclearized iranian iran would
be an existential threat
to them and here like given the
relationship between
america and israel
is really difficult to see anyway
of america not
commit committing itself to the strategy
of prevention and this complicates the
matter more with with the iranians that
they can actually make hay of what is
happening in syria and actually fueling
that so what i want to say is that among
these actors like the iranian the
israelis the american the russians they
should be like a kind of talk and agree
on
how to respect and acknowledge their
mutual interests or their separate
interest in um in the region i think
then the
political solution would be would be
possible
briefly
well the point is and
i do agree that there is a possibility
if if if
the dynamics started to roll on i mean
if if we have a move on the chemical
weapons a diplomatic one maybe as
professor charles says yeah yeah the
model united nations when the uh
the bazaar mentality will like control
and like negotiating and bargaining
before even you start the actual
negotiations this is this is our part of
the world and this is what we do all the
time but
and but on the other hand if you just if
the u.s
as i said exercise leadership and put an
objective an objective and and it says
very clearly that it will put the enough
resources in order to reach this
objective then my
dynamics might be created in order to
reach this objective one thing is that
you have to you have to identify and
make the russians identify what what
they need actually in syria what is
their interest maybe is it tartus naval
facility i think it's one of their
interests but it's not a very big big
one there is like another is it like
they need men in this regime and the
establishment of the of the coming
regime so they need part of the military
and part of the security agencies to be
part of the new regime maybe the us and
the world the the anybody who wants to
solve this the syrian crisis needs to
identify to help and actually to help
the russians and possibly the iranians
identify their
real interests in syria and maybe then
we can reach a compromise because
otherwise it's like russia is speaking
about the different world order and the
us speaking about the rise of the rest
so it's not gonna it's it will not go
anywhere this way and very briefly
very very briefly yeah right i slightly
disagree with you actually on whether or
not elsa can stay and that's a i
recognize this is a fairly radical
statement but this is getting to your
point of thinking about what different
groups need and what different actors
need i mean there is also we are tending
to stick
to think within sort of the unified
syrian ocean and i'm not i'm not
advocating this i'm simply saying that
there are many ways in which these
negotiations can actually take place and
there's many different sort of potential
solutions out there so part of it is
what do you what do you need do you need
the naval base do you need et cetera
part of it is you know that these the
extent to which the 30 of the population
that actually supports assad is actually
not necessarily sprinkled across the the
state i mean it's clear that that there
are pockets where you know you can
imagine the north actually sort of
breaking away you can imagine
actually for the whole region and again
this is not an advocation i want to make
that very clear but but the the realm of
possibilities goes beyond simply
what's the
what's the chips that we can trade over
the state as it looks like today and
given the sort of the players who are
there and i think that's an important
thing to recognize right
i will take two more questions in this
case and one is in the frontier
is the assumption that iran is
so you mean in this case that there is
the fact that uh
they're they speak a different language
in this case makes it makes a
significant difference in personal
strategy
leading the pan arab sort of yeah i
think it's a very important point
uh very important
and maybe fundamentally over the long
run
that will be the um deciding factor
but the iranian regime
going back to the ayatollah romani has
thought about that and addressed it
and
in its ideology which is a very
much revision
structured ideology
revisionist in the sense of changing the
shia faith itself and the way it's
managed
uh
thought itself as being able to bridge
that gap
and they've got
arabic speakers and they've got
their supporters inside iraq in an arab
shia led country
uh they've got hezbollah they've got
shia populations that are
uh in the the west of the region
hezbollah particularly on the
mediterranean
so there's a kind of an archipelago of
iranian-backed shia and some others who
are sunni as well
that the iranians have done a lot to
cultivate as in the case of hamas in in
gaza
so
it's a strategy
it's a strategy that's backed by and i
think this is a big factor in the drive
for nuclear weapons
when you get nuclear weapons the most
important thing is you don't have to use
them people are just scared of you
and pretty soon they will begin to
gravitate in your direction
particularly in the middle east where
the primary motivation is fear
that is who's going to be in charge of
me next month
and if the iranians can back that up
with their ideology and their strategy
uh
they've been trying that pretty well
but you may your question may ultimately
be the correct one they may not be able
to do it because they're not arab
muhammad briefly
okay very very briefly well i
i tend to agree and disagree with
professor charles hill here iran is a
strong player a very strong player in
the region but it can never actually i
mean
to put it more uh precisely it's very
overestimated to think that it's going
to be the hegemon over the region it's
not arab it's not sunni and
shiite arabs are shiite chairs in
general attempt only 10 percent of the
whole
muslim community in the world and on
another hand
the experience of hames
iran has helped and supported hamas for
years and
whether by money or by training or even
armament but then when it came
a moment when the
sunni shiite
factor emerged hamas actually decided
would be sunni did not side with iran
and we hamas left syria hamas is not in
syria any longer
does not does not support bashar
al-assad actually they stand uh very
openly against them and against the
iranian interest so
iran will iran a big
a big country big big history i don't
see it as a
power of good in the region it has it
iran is doing uh
a lot of bad things and to many
countries in the region but
it can it's very much overestimated to
say that they are going to humanize over
our over most of them
i just want to add that i think iran has
um
proxy um
assets and capabilities in
in in the measure of the levant and the
gulf of course like you know houthi in
yemen and also in bahrain
we cannot underestimate iran until up
until 2006
uh the iranian ahmadinejad was among the
most popular in the middle east among
the arabs even
research center headed by sardine
ibrahim uh put
ahmadinejad only after hasanah so all
shia they were i'm here i'm talking
about the sample was sunni completely
sunny but again here that's the
importance of what is happening in syria
it really polarized the region now iran
is seen
differently uh
hassan nasrallah is no longer
popular in in jordan for instance or in
in the west bank or in gaza in egypt
even
even worse so i think the shia sunni
factor is
will be detrimental to the iranian
outreach in the region and the iranian
influence in in the region
there's one one word which is the
interesting thing about the support for
iran it was which was also with
nasrallah was that it was actually
because they stood up to the israelites
in 2006. well to israeli but also the
iran and vis-a-vis the west and as as
seen as sort of the bulwark against it
so the interesting thing is if it did
become a hegemon it would lose actually
that status which is kind of a
twist
and we should say that hasan nasrallah
in this case is the leader of hezbollah
of course now the last question please
no the woman in the black hair i'm sorry
i'm sorry about that yes
because of their support of the assad
regime even among shia and iraq and
elsewhere because they're so upset about
the massive killings of this the
chemical warfare but just just you know
the brutality of the assad machines
that's one thing we've been talking very
much in terms of the top down but let's
think about the bottom up the other
question is uh is also an empirical
question which is about um you know the
threat just the threat of u.s strikes
from what i understand i've been saying
of course there have been mass
defections from
itself is a very interesting point it
says something about
what the potential of a us strike could
mean and then if i could just make one
very very short comment which is that i
think if we've learned one thing from
the arab spring as far as this idea that
the you know the region is going to lose
the nation state and what would the
local debate what would the political
formation look like
one thing we've learned from the arab
spring i don't like that term
maybe the empirical question first do we
know anything about defections in this
case yeah okay i can answer to this i
mean there has been defections but they
are not massive defections actually
because now there is some we we have to
know that there are many factors now
unifying the forces of asset one of them
is interest one of them is sectarian and
one of them is ideological and
we cannot
and and the and the more importantly is
that the absence of alternative so okay
so where are they going after after
defection so there has been defections
but not uh massive and that cannot
actually
change the balance on the ground
i i have just i need to respond to the
question of the national
national nation state well i have this
is not part of any uh
official or institutional beliefs but i
have i i do not really see a nation
state in the arab world we do not have
nation states most of the especially in
the masjid most of the states have been
actually created by colonial powers in
in in this way there is no nation state
the nation is whether it's the arab or
the muslim or maybe we can trace some
syrian traces but the borders and
the the way the the states have been
created are not actually nation states
and they will not they have not been
created and healthy and
did not we're not given healthy
time and healthy environment to uh to
prove to to produce a sense of
nationhood and this is something i have
witnessed in syria
there is
a very high sense of region region
locality in syria so a person from homs
and a person from damascus a person from
aleppo
they in a way feel different they do not
really feel that they belong to a
certain thing certain state so this is
something that maybe needs to evolve in
order to have like maybe uh nasser was
right we need about uh pan-arabism maybe
or maybe we
maybe there are uh tons of and huge
possibilities uh out there as professor
lust
spoke
does the panel want to end
well so thank you very much our panel
for
thank you for attending thanks very much